hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about what is the
absolute best diet for swollen feet and
ankles okay
now the first thing you need to know is
if you have this condition you have to
realize it so it's a major problem it's
not a little thing and lot of times
people kind of brush it off as well use
have food retention
go to the doctor get lasix or a diuretic
and push the fluid out no you need to
really realize that it's a major problem
either with the liver or the kidney or
the heart and you really need to take a
systemic approach or a whole body
approach because what's happening in
your ankles is happening in other places
too and there's several mechanisms like
for example you can have an imbalance
with electrolytes okay but that's more
unlikely because when you have like
either pitting edema you're pressing in
there it's usually the organ that is
failing so it's usually more of a low
protein in the blood now it's not just a
matter of eating more protein to get
more protein or blood so you can push
the fluid out that's not going to work
because really the liver and the kidney
are not allowing the production of the
right types of protein like your liver
takes from the blood amino acids and
makes a certain protein called albumin
which goes in the blood and then it
actually helps in the transmission of
fluid to the blood and when you don't
when this conversion doesn't happen
because the liver is damaged then you
get all this this low protein albumin in
the blood and then the fluid kind of
goes out of the blood alright so the
protein keeps the fluid in the blood you
know correctly so here's what you have
to do as a foundation you need to get
the diet corrected and it starts with
vegetables that is the first thing you
need to start including
if you're doing like a cup of vegetables
that are steamed or cooked you're never
going to get well you're going to have
to do large quantities of raw salads and
vegetables we're not talking about
romaine or sorry iceberg lettuce I'm
talking about spinach kale high-quality
vegetables because this has a lot of
great things
enzymes and minerals to help push the
fluid out and also make you feel better
but also people do like apple cider
vinegar which is a great thing sometimes
they'll do certain fruit juices like
watermelon juice or melon juice to push
the fluid out that will work but it's
usually temporary so you just have to
start including vegetables in the diet
for the potassium the enzymes and also
just to heal the organs quality protein
you don't want to do if you have
swelling in ankles don't be doing like
protein powders you want to do like high
quality from the health food store grass
fed either beef or fish or seafood you
want to do a high quality protein okay
not a fast food you know burger that's
not going to work you're going to have
to get the sugar out for sure that's a
given I'm not even saying that because
I'm assuming you already know that but
you cannot have sugar around this at all
because sugars is going to cause
swelling just on it and itself now the
other thing that's really powerful is an
enzyme called Serra pep taste okay
you've never heard about this you need
to know about this Serra pepper taste
basically will dissolve scar tissue it
gets rid of fibrous unwanted tissue it
dissolves clots in the arteries and
improve circulation
it helps inflammation it also will help
other cirrhosis on the liver see what
happens with the liver is it has an
inflammation State and in a develop scar
tissue and most people with this a demon
in the feet have a bit of cirrhosis at
scar tissue in the liver this enzyme
will help to dissolve that so this
enzyme comes from a silkworm okay but I
think they can now make it they can
ferment it and make it in a certain way
I don't know the whole mechanics but
this is one of the best solutions for
fluid because it opens up your
circulation it helps repair the liver
especially the scar tissue and also the
kidney too so it just gets the
circulation going for you now can
actually have a better protein and
to happen this is a very powerful enzyme
for proteins
okay but it won't harm your own body's
proteins it only seems to go after the
proteins that shouldn't be there so
that's good for so many things so anyway
that's what I'm going to recommend if
you have this and I would get it's a
little pricey to get something but I
would get something like get 120
international 120 thousand international
units or maybe even you can find at 250
thousand I use of this enzyme and take
it several times a day on an empty
stomach if you take it with food it
won't work okay so it goes into the
blood and starts cleaning and that's a
real good way to correct a liver but the
reason I talked about this last is that
I want you to correct the diet first so
you're not just dependent on some pill
magical pill that's going to heal
everything you have to fix it up but
this is just going to enhance everything
and really get you in good shape alright
thanks for watching put your comments
below